Ja irgendwie ist es wirklich verhext der dunkle materie sie ist einfach nicht aufzuspüren zwar können wir sie immer wieder beobachten zb durch
gravitationslinsen also
Verzerrung des lichts hinter der dunklen materie es muss sie also irgendwie
Geben aber noch kein einziges teilchen der dunklen materie wurde gefunden und das soll jetzt anders werden
ein forschungsteam hat jetzt einen empfänger für die wellen dieser teilchen konstruiert
Er soll den durchbruch bringen jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Und verdammt noch
Mal das kann doch einfach nicht sein wir wissen dass es sie gibt aber wo ist sie noch kein
einziges teilchen der dunklen materie wurde bisher gefunden höchst verdächtig die wimps die weekly interacting massive particles
Also die schwach interagierenden massiven teilchen der name liefert schon die erklärung dafür warum diese
hypothetisch also auf nur
vermuteten teilchen nicht gefunden werden sie interagieren nur sehr schwach mit anderen teilchen kann nicht keine chemische reaktionen
Einfach nur sehr sehr wenig wenn es sie überhaupt gibt doch die für sie gibt nicht auf dort kannten
Physik gibt es ja nicht nur teilchen sondern auch wellen und zwar gleichzeitig ein teilchen ist eine welle und umgekehrt das berühmte
doppelt spalt experiment zeigt das ziemlich beeindruckend lasse
ich nicht durch zwei spalten fallen verhalten sie sich dahinter wie wählen sie bilden
interferenzen dahinter wie wellen und keine schatten messe ich dagegen durch welchen spalt die lichtteilchen fliegen dann gibt es keine interferenzen
sondern die beiden spalte werden dahinter projiziert also
Abgebildet es sind teilchen die durch die spalten fliegen also total verrückt für die teilchen der dunklen materie bedeutet dies dass sie nicht nur durch
teilchendetektoren gefunden werden können sondern eben auch durch wellen detektoren und genau den einen solchen haben us forscherinnen und forscher
Jetzt gebaut ein dunkle materie radio die wimps die müssen sie eigentlich durch die ihre
gammastrahlung entdeckt werden können die bei ihren kollisionen entsteht
bisheriges ergebnis
0 deshalb wird jetzt nach leichteren teilchen gesucht beziehungsweise deren wellen so genannte aktionen oder
Dunkle photonen also lichtteilchen die allerdings kein licht transportieren ihre wellen sollen jetzt selektiert werden an der stanford university
Wurde jetzt der prototyp eines solchen detektor entwickelt noch kann ja nur in einem sehr engen frequenzbereich
Suchen aber er soll schon bald erweitert werden zitat es ist großartig dass wir dieses neue detektoren konzept mit einem
instrument ausprobieren können das relativ wenig kostet und kaum risiken birgt
das sagt erin fips vom camel institute also
Keine riesen technik soll ein ganz einfaches instrument das so gar nicht
mal groß
vor kosmischer strahlung geschützt werden muss das geschieht mit einer dünnen schicht aus
supraleitende materialien und auch bei empfänger modul kommt supraleitung zum einsatz in form eines supraleitenden
Quanten interferenz gerätes es wird mit einem
besonders
rauscharmen
elektronische verstärker kombiniert ob es damit endlich gelingt die teilchen oder wellen der dunkle materie zu entdecken es wird spannend oder
Besteht die dunkle materie doch auch etwas ganz anderem ihr werdet es hier auf jeden fall bei klicks und science fiction erfahren
Mir einfach ein abo aufs auge drücken damit er kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen verpasst und nicht vergessen den
Auf die glocke dann gibt es nämlich immer einen hinweis wenn es ein neues video gibt und hier geht es weiter mit einer sehr spannenden
käse dunkle materie rätsel gelöst spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle unbedingt anschauen draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran